but we begin with the latest
developments in the corona virus there
are now more than a hundred thousand
confirmed cases of the corona virus here
in the US the most infections in any
country in the world but headway is
being made against the disease and its
effects on Friday the FDA cleared a new
test that can detect corona virus in
about five minutes and president Trump
signed a historic 2.2 trillion dollar
bill aimed at helping businesses and
individual Americans New York continues
to be the epicenter of cases here in the
United States with more than 46,000 Tom
Hanson is at Elmhurst Hospital in Queens
Tom good morning good morning Dana and
Jeff we'll just behind me nearly two
dozen people have already lined up to
get tested for Cova 19 at the Elmhurst
Hospital here in Queens this has been
referred to as the epicenter of the
epicenter at least 13 people died here
in a matter of just 24 hours this place
is taking on New York City's avalanche
of cases across the u.s. the unwelcome
distinction of being number one has many
faces in Georgia intensive care units at
all four major Atlanta hospitals filled
to the max in Alabama an infant named
Emory is sick and separated from her
heartbroken parents the nurse manager
walked in and informed me that a nurse
that had taken care of Emory within the
past two weeks had actually tested
positive for coronavirus so every every
baby that she had contact with was now
isolated with us cases exceeding 100,000
and threatening to overwhelm medical
systems some governor's brought in
military manpower a navy hospital ship
named mercy anchored Friday in the San
Pedro California Harbor set to handle
1,000 patients if Los Angeles area
hospitals fill up it's just one of many
assets that were already pre positioning
throughout the state of California the
military is converting New York City's
Convention Center to a 1,000 bed
emergency hospital
in the worst case scenario the u.s.
medical providers will need 900,000
ventilators compared to the 160,000
available now it is a battle but it will
be over it will be over at some point in
the coming months but when in San
Francisco with the longest-running
shelter at home order the mayor told
residents Friday to keep their eye on
the ball how much longer can we take it
well the fact is we're gonna have to
take it a little bit longer because it
does mean that we save lives
cutting exposure may be working but
without adequate test results it's still
hard to know but there are successes
clay Bentley spent 12 days in a Georgia
hospital after doctors tried antibiotics
he was allowed to be quarantined at home
more than 900 people stricken with the
virus have recovered clay Bentley is
just one of them now New Yorkers have
simply been asked just to stay home
other states like New Jersey and
Connecticut - but nearby Rhode Island
has made headlines for reports that
they're trying to shoo away New Yorkers
who are looking for a place to stay in
fact there are also reports that police
are pulling over cars with New York
license plates in order to gather
contact information Jeff well alright
Tom thank you very much